[Music]
way more Hank Hank it's been such a long
day that I have to talk to you about it
here in the car at night with the crazy
light on that makes me look like I'm a
serial killer
first I visited with kids at this school
Hank can you imagine if like a Spanish
language or french language author
showed up in an American high school and
started talking to them in Spanish or
French and yet these kids were quite
attentive some of them it must be said
seemed to speak English better than I do
then I got my picture taken and I stood
on this sign which was really scary
because I'm afraid of heights even if
the height is only 4 feet why don't you
stand up John I think it'll be easier
don't be crazy Hank you wanna do
something interesting about the
Netherlands it's easy to tell who the
German tourists are they're always
wearing camo pants even the babies Hank
I tried to film these windmills for you
but a gasoline truck got in the way Hank
this is a bitter ball
yeah and this is mustard everyone at the
cafe finds this very funny I'm now going
to eat a bigger ball than last time with
mustard very delicious you know it
tastes like it tastes like if you took
meat and flour and hope and you fried it
then I did my happy dance man I love
doing my happy dance Hank my happy dance
is huge in the Netherlands it's so huge
that later when I went to Rotterdam
pictured here people in my Dutch
publisher the best publisher in all of
Holland we're like hey can you do your
happy dance outside the restaurant where
we're taking you out to dinner
hey the people of Memphis cut my happy
dance
sure so he stopped because I think I
think they're trying to figure out if
that was illegal Bank the yetis response
to your brilliant song will have to wait
until Monday I'll see you tomorrow